good morning Hank it's Monday October
6th and today's video comes to you in
ten parts 10 yes 10 let's get on with it
[Music]
part 1 Hank as you can probably see I
just got back from Berlin Germany Hank
those nerdfighters included Jenny who
got me that flag and also recipes for my
hat whose channel is kind of like songs
from a hat only with food part 2 but
before I was in Berlin
I guess this vlog is going to be unstuck
in time like Billy Pilgrim I was in
Minneapolis where I met hundreds of made
of Awesome nerdfighters and Hank I
received several special presents
including my first copy of the Spanish
translation of Looking for Alaska and
this Shakespearean insult gum featuring
insults from seven different
Shakespearean plays I'm gonna try some
King Lear here hmmmm you toad spotted
traitor added some delicious insulting
part three back to the future when we
got to our hotel room in Berlin I pulled
up in the curtains and there was this
beautiful view and I was like Sarah come
look at this beautiful view and I knew
there was something a little bit weird
about the church but I couldn't figure
out what was weird about the church
until Sarah pointed out to me that most
of the steeple had been dissed eople
fied so much for the theory that writers
have to have unusually developed powers
of observation part 4 german insult tank
it's no secret that I'm a big fan of
German insults for instance I use the
word sits Pickler which means a man who
sits to pee like a hundred times in my
second novel I learnt a new one while I
was in Germany vom Ducie it means like a
man who takes hot showers by the way
heck I am a total vom Ducie like I'm
actually a vom batha part 5 Hank my trip
to Berlin featured two moments of really
trippy musical incongruity the first
game when I was beating two high school
students in a large room that featured
literally every single children's book
published in the GDR the old communist
East Germany so here I am in this room
full of historically important communist
children's books and the headmaster guy
he brought a CD that kind of reflected
the roots of Looking for Alaska
then like two hours later I'm in this
tiny bar where the walls are brown not
because they were painted brown but
because of cigarette tar and it's the
kind of bar where they put antlers on
the wall but they don't even bother to
remove the skulls and then on comes
everybody hurts by r.e.m part six
alcoholic dogs Hank that bar had a dog
that used to hang out and drink there
you're looking at his picture now and
that reminded me of the great fireball
Roberts the alcoholic Bulldog and James
Crumm Lee's novel the last good kiss
Hank Crumley died a couple weeks ago in
your hometown of Missoula Montana he was
a damn good writer and he'll be missed
part seven Hank as you know because you
helped me do it all of the events for
the Paper Towns and nerdfighting tour
are now available on Facebook with
up-to-date information we are no longer
using eventful calm because it has
become our mortal enemy long story if
you go to nerdfighters calm and look
there on the left it lists all of the
events in order you can click and RSVP
and invite your friends please invite
your friends and it will be awesome part
eight chessboxing so Hank when I was in
Germany a lot of times when I would go
to schools I wouldn't actually read my
book on account of how I don't read or
speak German an actor would and it turns
out that one of those actors is actually
one of the world's best chess boxers I
Hank justify reading with your brother
John was a wonderful experience and I
just want to say hi I'm the runner up
European champion and heavyweight chess
boxing chess boxing alternates between
four minutes of the game of chess in two
minutes of boxing you can win by either
knockout or checkmate I mean Hank that
is an actual literal nerdfighter part 9
Hank my new book Paper Towns comes out
in 10 days but nerdfighters if you can't
wait I'd encourage you to read let it
snow a holiday romance anthology by me
Maureen Johnson and Lauren Myracle
that's a very masculine cover also they
sent me like way too many author copies
for let it snow so I'm going to give
away five to random commenters on this
video and finally part 10 Hank today
marks the first day of our month-long
Brotherhood 2.0 style vlogging challenge
so for the first time in almost 10
months I literally mean it when I say
Hank I'll see you tomorrow
PS scavenger hunters I love Seattle
I love wizard Rock and I love snakes